bien alors pascal sevran pour vous
changer les idées
ouais on va vous faire une interview
cauchemar on prend le volant dans le
qinghai
je vais parler reparler par le bon a
nuancé ont accès c'est vrai c'était tu
as raison mais je suis comme ça mais
j'ose pas des foires fêtes
je veux pas du tout avoir et qui gérait
en fait on va le faire serge on est
obligés de leur faire il a il a parlé
ont valu en bouche à bouche mais ne
bougent pas pendant le jingle en le
bouchant les kings voilà c'est mieux
quand c'est plus propre bien alors voilà
donc la table cauchemar le pire truc le
pire des accidents conjugaux c'est de
vous faire surprendre par votre amant
avec un autre de surprendre votre amant
avec meilleurs amis sinon le pire
cauchemar c'est de trouver la personne
que l'on aime entre andry ravec
quelqu'un d'autre à 30 coucher ouais
c'est pas très grave bonnes réponses et
vous djamel que vous arriver de pire
c'est de vous faire surprendre par votre
amant avec un autre ou des surprendre
votre amant avec votre meilleure amie ne
marche pas avec le pire cadeau qu'on
puisse vous faire une perceuse sans fil
des vacances avec vanessa paradis ou
l'intégrale de y'a pas photo en vidéo
l'intégrale de y'a pas photo allez ça va
loin la pire situation dans laquelle
vous pourriez vous trouvez pascal sevran
avoir une cigarette mais pas de feu une
carte bleue mais pas de code
un mec sublime mais pas de préservatif
je me doutais bien qu'avec vous c'est le
service public en même temps mais je me
devais réussir ça c'est le service
public cigarettes et pas de feu ouais
c'est une version à vous pour gens c'est
ça que j'aurais dit un pétard mais pas
trop non lui c'est pas il les avale les
joints la pires désillusions ça serait
d'apprendre qu'il ya quelqu'un dans
casimir que thierry lafont a mis une
chaussette dans son collant ou que
chirac est mêlé à la sphère des hlm de
paris que thierry la fronde la mine et
le pire c'est un portable qui sonne tout
le temps ou qui sonne jamais assez un
portrait puis sommes tout le temps ah
ouais c'est pas besoin qu'on vous
appelle toute la journée cette maladie
terrible touche ça comme leur secte sont
couchés il met rennes la bouche
il parle alors chiens ils sont tout le
temps face et un terrible et où ces
signes extérieurs de détresse ah bravo
ça pourrit la vie mais qui quand même
nous pire c'est grandir salle vivre seul
ou vieillir seul vieillir sol un le pire
c'est de ne plus pouvoir toucher la
personne avec qui vous vivez ou de plus
vouloir la toucher a de plus pouvoir le
problème de réussi c'est une occasion
qui te mets dans la réalité de la vie
agricole le pire quand on est plaqué le
pire c'est de l'apprendre par une lettre
un coup de fil ou par quelqu'un ça m'est
arrivé quelquefois mais je savais avant
donc je devrais on veut ne m'apprend
rien généralement dans ce domaine le
pire c'est d'apprendre que dieu n'existe
pas ou qu'il existe mais ce n'est pas le
vôtre qu'il existe et que c'est pas bien
djamel pareil
pascal sevran lendemain
5 chanter la vie
changer la vie des cellules sanguines
nous changer
je m'en vais pourquoi ah bon je te reste
est d'acord parce qu'il était à mon âge
oh non on va rester je reste bon